[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
dataprep by trifacta can transform your
raw data into ready-to-use data
pipelines for your analytics or machine
learning
dataprep is a data engineering platform
to discover combine and transform data
using clicks instead of code dataprep
automates data pipelines to supply clean
data at scale to your data initiatives
with dataprep you can connect to a wide
range of disparate data and transform it
inside an intuitive user interface to
prepare it for your analytics
once inside dataprep automatically
discovers data structure and patterns
surfaces data quality issues and
provides guidance to resolve them using
machine learning dataprep interprets
your interactions and suggests data
transformations you can preview select
and edit suggestions to create recipes
dataprep is also collaborative allowing
you to work with others on your project
and build collective knowledge across
your organization
with just a few clicks without any code
you can orchestrate an entire data
pipeline at scale for bigquery and data
flow dataprep is an integrated partner
service operated by trifacta it's
browser-based serverless scalable and
inherits google cloud security
principles to get started right away
just go to the google cloud console or
google cloud marketplace and select
dataprep to start wrangling data now and
the next time you're looking to prepare
data pipelines for your analytics data
science or machine learning take a
minute to explore dataprep by trifacta
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
dataprep
[Music]